good morning believe nation if Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in
people more than they believe in
themselves and my sincere hope is that
if you see in yourself what I see in you
you'll be able to change the planet so
to help you on your journey today's
message is be open to the unknown over
to you simon Sinek rarely are we instant
experts you may have a particular gift
or affinity toward something but you
still get better you know people would
pay me high compliments when I started
speaking and then people who've seen me
a year or two later say that I'm even
better and I feel it why because you you
you learn more you know I think that
hubris is dangerous I think to think
that you're an expert in anything is
that is a foolish pursuit you're never
you're never as good as you could be
there's always room for improvement
there's always room to get better you
don't that does mean you have to listen
to all the advice just you know not
necessarily because everybody know best
but but to believe that you can be
better and to believe that you can offer
more is a constant pursuit you know I
used to think being a public speaker
meant being poised and presenting in a
way that was compelling and speaking at
the right pace and that's that's a part
of it but but I have been taking more
risks lately doing things that are very
unstructured and very uncomfortable and
I will now do like if I have an hour to
speak I'd rather speak for 20 minutes
and do 40 minutes worth of questions and
who knows how that's going to go and
that to me is the best and so I'm a
better speaker because now I'm Way more
open to the unknown we're a few years
ago that that would have scared me one
of the greatest skills I think it can
master is to learn to be comfortable and
be uncomfortable to lean in on it to
feel the excitement and energy from it
as opposed to just the fear and
shrinking down this of it which is what
a lot of people do a lot of people are
super uncomfortable when there's a new
strange scary situation happening
want to lean in on that so you can grow
as a human but also you can bring the
most to your business a good habit to
try to get into is as soon as you think
of a new idea as soon as you come up
with something that you want to try you
want to talk to that person you want to
launch this new business you want to
create this new campaign assuming you
have that idea find some small way to
take immediate action on it one you're
more likely to follow through you're
more likely to build momentum and to
actually see some results coming from it
but to what happens is here's what
happens so often there's so many
entrepreneurs and it's so frustrating
it's so limiting for a lot of you guys
if you come up with an idea and you're
excited right like this could be a great
new idea I really want to try this thing
out and then you add more layers and
layers and layers and extrapolations and
this little tiny idea becomes this huge
big project and as you scale up the
project and it's exciting to think about
how you can make it this big thing right
if you want to launch a YouTube channel
it starts with one video and then you
think wow I need to have my banner are
they I need to have my production
schedule and you figure what lights and
what camera or microphone and you like
build up this huge project that is very
exciting but then the fear kicks in and
then it's like well how do I go out and
accomplish all those things I need a
team I need money I need resources
anytime I need to plan I need to
planning it's a point and you're stuck
in this constant planning mode and it
becomes such as such a big idea but then
you never do anything about it or if you
can cut that off sooner and as soon as
you get an idea while it's still little
of something that you want to try go
ahead and do it go and see how it works
see if you enjoy it if you want to do it
again I keep thinking back to dating as
an example where if you're about to meet
somebody for the first time if you're
already thinking long term if you're
already thinking about the wedding and
the kids and retirement in depth like
you're thinking all the way out there
you put in so much pressure that you
find out even going to say hi to this
person and you even know if it's ever
going to work out or just go out grab a
coffee see if you like them
see if you want to go up for another
coffee right I think as soon as you get
an idea to just try it and it's
uncomfortable and it's scary but just
try it in some small way I think about
my Malaysia speech
a couple years ago it was a meaningful
speech for me because the first time I
introduced your one word and believed to
an audience maybe I did it to you guys
first on YouTube but like to an actual
speaking audience and just before going
on stage I had a woman stop me at
breakfast and was talking about how she
was being cyber bullied and how it was
really impacting her negatively and she
was thinking of shutting down all her
social accounts and the impact that I
had in her family and just a really sad
story from a really beautiful wonderful
caring woman and I was about to get on
stage about to go do my second speech
and I just thought of this idea like
wouldn't it be great to involve her
somehow would it be great to get it give
her some recognition and have the people
in the audience support her and so I
brought her up on stage she had no idea
what was happening and I asked her you
know are you okay if I tell your story
but she said yes and I told her story
and then what I wanted people to do was
while I was speaking I had just my new
friend here to the side of the stage and
I said everybody what I want you guys to
do is come up and take a picture with
her put hashtag I think with hashtag
piece or hashtag love and anybody who
tagged me in the picture takes a picture
with her and has hashtag peace or love I
will give them I gave them one of my my
guides when an e-book download that I
had and while I was talking at the front
there was a huge line up and throat the
entire presentation people were taking
pictures with her and they were laughing
and they were smiling and there were
tears of joy and happiness and it really
made an impact on my new friend this
woman that I had met but also on
everybody coming through that this was
something that was really important and
it made the talk that much more valuable
to everybody and it just happened spur
the moment this was not a planned thing
if she didn't come and meet me at
breakfast and stop me and say hi and
tell me her story I wouldn't have done
that I would have just continued with my
regular regular client speech and so I
think it's good to have a plan but it's
good to make adjustments it's good to
lean into the unknown I had this idea
and instead of making it this big thing
that I could save for the next time I do
is be to the next time this thing
happens I'm going to do something right
now and it may work and it may not work
out but I'm going to test it and that
one worked out really well but sometimes
it doesn't work out right sometimes you
fall on your face sometimes you think
you do that jump and you can't make it
and you fall down that's going to happen
too but I try to embrace the approach if
I would rather no and fail did not know
then just live in my head because I
would hate to think that here is this
woman who I could have helped who could
have made a meaningful contribution to
and all these people in a room that I
could have helped them in a meaningful
contribution to but I was too scared to
do it I was too scared of releasing an
imperfect plan and so I did nothing and
that's too often what we do in our
business and in our lives
we had this idea and we're too afraid to
release an imperfect plan and we do
nothing as a result there will never be
a perfect plan you can think up a plan
all you want but as soon as you start to
get out there into the world and test it
your plan will change every single
successful business the plan they
started with is not the plan that
ultimately helped them grow
it was part of their plan that they had
to change it had to adapt and so too
many of us are just stuck in our heads
and we don't take enough action and so
it strongly encouraged you the next time
you feel uncomfortable next time you're
feeling nervous about something next
time you get that little queasy feeling
you know votes I don't know if I should
do that or not to do it say yes embrace
the approach it you would rather know
and have it fail then live the rest of
your life with regrets because you are
too afraid to take some kind of action
so the question they tell you is I'm
curious what is something that you are
working on that you're afraid to release
that is imperfect but now you're going
to go out and push it and let people
know about it at least in a small way
I'm curious what is that project leave
it down the comments below
I'm really curious to find out and if
you leave a comment within the first
couple hours is video going live you
know change doing one of two daily
prizes I also want to give a quick
Charter to Chris and Juliana thank you
guys sort your picking up a copy of my
book your one-word and take
in that great picture in your car with
it I hope you enjoyed the read and I
really appreciate the support thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso
[Music]
do something new you know you've got to
make you've got a cancer in your comfort
zone that's what we all do we get to a
certain age whilst in earth comfort zone
with the recliners watching television
day in there and we get certain aging
receptive in Aveiro I sit around
watching television through the rest of
my life because I've done it all sitting
on my laurels it reads it's not worth it
I mean life so short and such glorious
images in the world and such horror as
well but I want to see it all so I've
moved out of my comfort zone it's some
essential for me otherwise I may as well
die so I've done it I've broken every
rule in the book and not out of malice
or any telling anyone that I'll show you
I did it for to show myself I've showed
myself I looked in America I'll show you
one day they've done something
completely rewrote the music and I feel
limitless you want to grab me you've got
like the nomination furniture you want a
style where you want to go the ball but
you just so much like how'd you keep
going like what inspired you honestly I
pray always the tables you know if you
always learn something moving and you
have you can be inspired but I hope this
kind of fit and look at the past like I
did this until people like you Amamiya a
lot of stuff I don't really you know
think about it
in the same way because I see the new
things on the horizon and I don't feel
like I have to do the same thing over
and over I think if you're a creative
person then you kind of have to follow
your vibe it's an opportunity example
something interesting
you know how his sports truck thing
anymore then you can go for it and I was
just kind of never windows keeping felt
like I couldn't do I've got the right
people around me to I believe to join
anything happens on Wednesday for
everything you've done
I don't master at all but I persevered
through it all and it gives me a chance
to find the next thing to work on so I'm
a fighter you know I I know how to take
them as much as I've been given so so
when I for some reason felt that I had
this small bit of confidence to audition
for the drill team and I made sure I was
auditioning for captain not just to be a
part of the team which is not that was
not something that I normally did in my
life like step outside of my comfort
zone and do something where I was being
put out in front of people but I
auditioned and they made me captain and
the drill team coach Elizabeth cam tine
saw something in me immediately she saw
an ability that I had my body
proportions and she thought you or a
ballerina and I want to introduce you to
someone who's giving a free ballet class
at the Boys and Girls Club that she
already attend so I was not at all
interested in ballet but after about a
week of hiding out in the back of this
ballet class on the basketball court the
teacher Cynthia Bradley pulled me on and
I took my first class and socks and
shorts and the t-shirt